so i like throwing a curveball at the
beginning uh if someone has actually
never seen anything that you've done
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why
in terms of films
yeah uh
well
um
this
this would be a great
this would be a great sort of entree
into uh it's interesting because i
started in in in the theater and so to
be able to do a piece of
um a piece of theater classic on film
something that'll live on something that
people can watch and to be doing it on
this scale
uh with this level of talent and this
level of creators and collaborators um
i'd love for people to sort of see this
first um
and then maybe you know go and see i
don't know
something like compton app straight out
of compton afterwards or see in the
heights after that you know what i mean
and so it sort of continues to shake it
up
um
but yeah this one this one sort of rings
special to me right now because this is
a this is a
i mean i guess you could say bucket list
um but i never really imagined in my
wildest dreams that
this would be uh a film that i would
ever
one see uh come to light but to then be
a part of so
yeah honestly it would be it would
probably be this one and i'm in my very
short career by the way so you know
when when you found out that you got
this role and you know it's with joel
cohen and denzel and everybody did you
then think about just going to the store
and buying some lottery tickets because
that was the day that the [ __ ] was
getting crazy
everything i was like i i literally
thought i had i had deja vu and i again
i'm always like deja vu was like um when
i was on the phone when i was hanging
out with my reps i was like
i think it's the moment when god reminds
you that you're on the right path right
like it's that moment where you have a
out of body experience like i've been
here before i know what's going on or
something is aligning
and i wish i did go buy some lottery
tickets that day because i feel like
i'm serious i feel like uh i just hit
the hit the hit the lottery with that
one man and just the the artistic
lottery i mean you know there was no
time
to sort of
think about oh you know is this
something i want to do or did it it's
just like yes yes thank you
thank you i felt honored to to to take
it on so yeah
obviously like you and like the world
i'm i'm a huge fan of joel cohen and the
coen brothers what actually maybe
surprised you about working with joel
that perhaps you weren't expecting going
in
well i
i don't know i don't know what my
expectations were i just remember being
caught off guard by just
how cool joel cohen is he's just
down to earth and i just like talking to
him like literally you know
i mean
just he's just so easy to just get along
with and just chat
i mean we'd be standing out on the on
the you know doing a scene change or
something like that and i i went every
day moses and i
we would go sort of every day and just
sit down and just like watch it was like
school for us
and just sit there and just chat with
joel cohen about films or about life or
just and then you're sitting there like
pinching yourself because denzel watson
walks by and joins the conversation and
presses right here chilling like you
know it's just one of those um
he's incredibly disarming i remember the
first conversation we had he said
you probably know you know more about
this than i do and in my head i'm like
no sir no i don't you know but but um
but again that's the sign of a director
who is open collaborative those are the
great those are the great directors you
know the people who you trust denzel
always says trust the pilot um and
that's a pilot who i trust trusted
implicitly on this journey
um his specificity his his you know all
of that he was shakespeare it just also
feels like a match made in heaven that
he's doing shakespeare you know it's
just it sort of lends itself to sort of
the coin-esque genre that you know that
that we've sort of come to know and love
um i'm curious uh uh
so many questions for you when you're
filming that scene with denzel
a third act uh it's a climactic battle
at what point were you standing there
looking at denzel getting ready to film
a fight scene and sort of have to take
you did you ever like sort of have to
take yourself back a second and be like
are you kidding me like what
yeah yeah yeah yes of course yes is the
answer i
those are the out-of-body moments that
you have um
you know when you look across from
yourself
you're just like
you you're living like also it's like as
a kid you know you grow up you know
playing plants with swords and just
uh and then to imagine that now you're
doing it with one of the greatest you
know living actors of our generation and
um and you're doing it
while speaking shakespeare
no words no words man i just i knew i
was just lucky and i also was like again
that was like our first time doing it
that was like our first time uh
actually doing it together the day we
were shooting it we had rehearsed it
separately so there was that as well so
it's a lot of there's a lot of fun
uh i really loved bruno cinematography
in the film and at times it reminded me
of like german expressionism and you
know it's just so well done can you sort
of talk about working with bruno and
what your reaction was when you saw the
aesthetic
that's my dude
bruno is just again such an easygoing
person uh he speaks french so he was
trying to help me with my french uh
throughout the whole time he's like
trying to do this incredible film and
i'm just like trying to like learn
french from him um uh he is uh
obviously one of the great um
uh cinematographers and just just he
just understands it and he gets it and
him and joel's
um
uh the
language the way in which they talk
about things it's just so easy going and
i was just like wow this shorthand was
incredible um
but to be able to walk into that was
like walking into a piece of living art
you know from even from the set designs
and the way they lit it and the way they
um and the way mary zolfrey's you know
stephon you know
set designs and mary zofrey's um
costumes and how they all are in
dialogue with each other
and pushing this piece of cinema you
know just photo it just takes you into
this dreamscape
that is neither play nor f film but
somewhere in the middle
and
it's a ride that you don't want to get
off or you can't get off you know once
you start and that's just from you know
again their incredible
brain trust
last question for you um what do you
think it is about shakespeare's writing
that has stood the test of time that has
had so many different people come back
to it again and again to adapt it and
bring it to life
shakespeare um
i say it all the time he was a poet of
the streets that's what he was
he wrote for
um
[Music]
every man
he wrote about the kings and queens and
the the courts and the you know the
palace intrigue
and
he wrote these incredible plays
that have stood the test of time because
while the
while the characters change the the plot
stays the same
so while we over time
you know have come and gone and left
this earth to come and gone and walked
the earth and left
the characters stay the same you know
there's there's there's that uh i mean
sorry the plot
you know sort of stays the same you know
there's always the
people sort of fighting you know for
ambition
uh fate there's love there's mistrust
there's sacrifice there's all of these
things that we all know and love in the
beautiful poetry of it that helps us
wrap our minds around it
um and feel it
but
the plot stays the same
fill up you know it's just everything
everything will will have it will play
its course and i think that's the beauty
of shakespeare is that it just reminds
us of that and that's the beauty of you
know this this again like you watch a
film like this and you go
oh wow you know and you look at yourself
and you're like
what is fate what is choice do i have a
choice if i do choose this route what
are the sac what are the implications
you know and you you feel it in a
visceral way and that's what i love
about it man the music
i gotta go i just want to say again
congrats uh you were great in this
wishing nothing but the best thank you
very much steve's good to see you thanks
man
you